foreign my brother is about 10. we
really wanted to go camping without any
adults my parents agreed as long as we
we trained
we were living in the Arctic so it was
cold temperatures and storms and lizards
and bears
but we wanted them to succeed in their
little mini first outing we wanted to
raise the kids giving them the
confidence to do impossible things
you learn to do things yourself
because we need to be able to deal with
the worst case scenarios
the reality is if it's blowing 100
kilometers an hour and it's a storm
we're out of the middle of nowhere
nobody's coming out to get you
you know my parents knew that as well
there's no rescue operation if something
bad happens there's no Hollywood Grand
Finale
will be frozen we'll be dead we'll be
eaten by a polar bear
foreign go
so this ice behind us is uh
uh quite impressive to look at but um
it's not very impressive when we're
traveling through it
we weren't that far out when I remember
my brother
had this like shock
what'd you see from up there
one three more nights
we wanted to cross the Busia straight
looking out at it it seemed like a
really bad idea
we knew if we pushed across which was
the quickest way there's the risk that
somebody would fall through the water
and just disappear out there
so we're gonna Camp the night and see if
it solidifies
The Detour it would add about 500
kilometers to our total tread which
would put us in Jeopardy of running out
of snow and ice
[Music]
so we started the day in good hopes that
we could get to the other side
see that's a fox
do something birds don't make that sound
which would we need to see an arctic fox
but at the same time foxes tend to
follow polar bears
[Music]
polar bears are a huge risk anywhere in
the Arctic
especially
around Open Water
if that's where they hunt seals
our biggest fear
was having a pullover encounter in Camp
we had a bear fence basically a tripwire
which would hopefully wake us up
they're so quiet they can sneak up on
anything
[Music]